i'm here with the one and only mark moss
mark how are you doing i'm doing great
i'm having a good time being here with
everybody at the bitcoin conference it's
the highlight of the year it is a major
congrats on your book it's out now right
yeah we just dropped a book actually
just just got it here at the conference
picked them up for the first time i'm
super excited about it so we're talking
about the future of payments yeah i want
to understand your thoughts do you think
that we're actually going to see a world
where people are actually using bitcoin
as a medium of exchange yeah definitely
and this is where a lot of people get
wrong i just saw peter thiel talk from
stage and i hate to say peter thiel has
it wrong because he's forgotten more
than i'll ever learn but i think he's
got it a little bit wrong where he
charted and he showed gold being uh 12
trillion whatever and he showed that um
then you have uh bitcoin being 800
billion but then he said that we need
bitcoin would be a good store of value
but then we need ethereum
he said we need ethereum for velocity
and what happened is traditionally we
would need gold and silver solar silver
had more velocity goal was for storage
for for store value the thing that they
don't understand with bitcoin is it's
both it's store of value and it's
payment so on the lightning network we
can already transact bitcoin faster and
cheaper than any other cryptocurrency so
i definitely think we will eventually
but don't you think people are going to
be looking at bitcoin as that ultimate
store of value like gold and therefore
just not really want to you know spend
it i don't want to spend my bitcoin you
don't want to spend your bitcoin now
because you have fiat and so what
happens is bad money chases out good
gresham's law and so i want to spend my
fiat save my bitcoin but eventually on a
bitcoin standard we'll just say bitcoin
spend bitcoin et cetera and so it's an
evolution process that will get there
eventually um but like i said it's old
thoughts the old technology that we
would need two different systems because
gold was big heavy clunky it didn't make
sense but bitcoin can move at the speed
of light
and it could be the best savings so it
could be all-in-one and we were speaking
earlier you're saying there's a
connection between money and freedom
yeah tell me about that yeah so um
without the freedom of payments there is
no freedom period so in the united
states our constitution guarantees me
the the freedom of speech
well if i don't have money to buy a
computer by a phone print a pamphlet
build a website i have no speech they
guarantee me the right to assemble but
if i can't put gas in my truck or get a
hotel room how can i go assemble and so
without the freedom of payments there is
no freedom i was saying how you parks
who broke out of north korea
she said at the opposite which i had
never thought of and it's caused me to
think about where without freedom
there's no need for money
and so it's just the opposite way to
look at so money is freedom and freedom
takes without freedom there is no money
they're intertwined they're intertwined
and they're opposites of each other mark
thank you so much and enjoy the rest of
the conference thank you